let's go next to our caller from the 8th
1/2 area code who's calling today from 8
1 2 hello yeah oh hey David a big fan I
think half my family washes or so okay
um
what's your name no I wanted to I wanted
what do you say I said what's your name
where you calling from
Oh God some creme Bloomington great I
wanted to ask you hello yes I hear
I'm here yeah I hear you no I wanted to
ask you about tax policy because uh a
lot of people had this dumb idea on the
right that my taxes would only go
towards something that makes sense that
benefits me you have people on the right
say well why are my taxes going towards
some poor person's health care or wiring
my taxes going towards some person's
education and these are people and they
left even say it now to where here are
people like people who to judges say
that oh why are we subsidizing with
tuition free college by re subsidizing a
wealthy person's education and I wanted
to ask you what your opinions on it are
because personally I think it's a really
dumb idea this whole notion that oh my
taxes should only go towards something
that I think makes sense and said ok
we're going to collect taxes and
collectively decide where they need to
go so there's a very fair criticism
which is that the individual has
relatively little say over where their
taxes go like if I don't like where tax
money is going at the federal level I
can try to get a different senator and
member of Congress elected and they
would be one out of a hundred or four
hundred and thirty five votes
respectively like it's very difficult
for what I want to be done with with tax
money to be made policy that's a very
fair criticism of the system that we
have with regard to this idea that you
you know the tax money needs to be spent
on what I want it's all the me me me
what I want idea that you hear on tax
policy from the right
you can't run a country that way I mean
humans once you get beyond a hundred and
fifty people or so you need some
structure some infrastructure that
we'll be deputized to make decisions in
ways that hopefully are representative
of what people want I mean if you read
Guns Germs and Steel by Jared Diamond he
goes he explains this in detail when you
look at hunter-gatherer bands of a few
families and then growing you know into
fiefdom Xand tribes like a vet you just
need some kind of system and it is a
system that one of its faults is not the
desires of every individual cannot
impossibly all be made reality but the
alternatives are anarchic chaos that's
the thing the right usually will if you
press them on it they'll say well just
whoever has the biggest guns gets to
decide or you have no taxation
whatsoever and everybody just keeps all
their money and builds a little piece of
road and charges people to use it or
whatever you get into these libertarian
fantasies so it's it's extraordinarily
immature often when people go in this
direction with tax policy arguments so
it's a how you said argue against people
on the right who argued this mode of
thinking that you know in a democracy we
can't possibly have your voice be
amplified for wherever you think taxes
should be allocated or I would concede
that in a country of three hundred and
forty million people it's completely
impractical for every individual to say
here's how my tax money is spent that
the way we make our voices heard is
through the elected officials that we
put in power that obviously many of them
have been corrupted by the campaign
finance system and corporations and
super PACs and all of that and that's
what we need to change and focus the
area to focus the conversation there
yeah thank you all right thanks for the
call I very much appreciate it let's
take a quick break if you're holding
don't hang up because I will go right
back to the phones when we come back at
six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty don't hang up going right
back to the phones